if the taliban are watching
what would you say to them i'm asking
the taliban to stop their brutality
leave killing sit down with love and we
should find solutions
so
[Music]
we are working in three phases the first
is to stop the defeats the second is to
regather our forces to create security
rings around the cities
all those soldiers that abandoned their
posts were bringing them back to their
posts
the third is to begin offensive
operations
[Music]
[Music]
unfortunately with their withdrawal the
fighting started in 400 areas of the
country we have very limited air support
the helicopters have been busy with
moving supplies and evacuating our dead
and injured forces
[Music]
after the taliban attempted to
assassinate the defence minister and
promised to target other government
leaders security around minister
murzakwell has never been tighter a
simple task of visiting checkpoints
requires this many special forces
i'm a soldier a soldier never gets
frightened
when we wear this uniform it means we
are ready for death i'm not worried
about it
[Music]
there are concerns from the
international community about these
uprising forces at the moment but all
their members will eventually merge into
the afghan national security forces
[Music]
[Music]
if the taliban are watching
what would you say to them i'm asking
the taliban to stop their brutality
leave killing sit down with love and we
should find solutions
i'm asking them not to destroy buildings
or our achievements
let's come and sit together and make a
coalition government one that would be
acceptable to all sides the sooner we do
this the better
[Music]
you